longtime hollywood legend and comedian
bob saggett has died at the age of 65.
in his celebrated career he became a
household name thanks to the wide range
of sterling performances he put forth
saga became known by millions when he
played the fun-loving single father of
three young girls in the hit sitcom full
house
other notable performances include his
parts on the show entourage in which he
plays an outlandish celebrity by the
familiar sounding name of bob saget he
was also very well known for hosting
america's funniest home videos for the
first eight seasons that the show was on
the air oh and of course he played the
narrator in the hit sitcom how i met
your mother zaggett came out of the gate
strong as a young stand-up and sitcom
star but he didn't exactly slow down in
his later years in fact if anything it
appears that the star felt invigorated
and ready to take on the world zagat's
final year of life saw him return to his
first love stand-up comedy in fact he
was performing on stage before adoring
audiences practically up to the moment
he was discovered dead at a ritz-carlton
hotel in orlando florida like the man
himself saggit's final year contained
multitudes and it most certainly wasn't
boring let's take a look at the last 12
months of bob saget's life as a comedian
with a strong background as a live
performer the stage played a
considerable part in sagat's life
as it happens he spent much of his last
year on a truly epic stand-up comedy
tour he performed his final show outside
of jacksonville florida and punctuated
it with the now bittersweet twitter
declaration that he was quote happily
addicted again to this
the nationwide tour began in september
of 2021 and was to continue until the
spring of 2022 zagat was clearly psyched
about his return to stand-up he wrote in
his final instagram post i had no idea i
did a two-hour set tonight i'm back in
comedy like i was when i was 26 i guess
i'm finding my new voice and loving
every moment of it along with this
stand-up tour sagat spent much of the
past year working on his podcast here
for you on which he and his guests
discuss all the twists and turns that
come with life and how to handle them
episodes of the show have featured a
wide variety of sagitt's friends
including fellow comedians george lopez
and bill burr bob saget's return to his
stand-up roots had him in high spirits
for the last 12 months of his life and
in a july 2021 interview with alabama
life and culture he reflected on his
career both the illustrious past and his
future plans yeah i kind of got my
dreams when it came to getting known and
getting success but i always thought i
had so much more than i wanted and i'm
still always hungry i never would retire
i'm always working work is something
that gives me fulfillment bob zaggett's
work situation was clearly incredibly
fulfilling but work alone isn't
necessarily enough to make a person
happy fortunately saggitt's professional
glories were far from the only great
thing he had going on because his
personal life was also very much in
order during his last 12 months near the
end of 2021 sagat's wife journalist
kelly rizzo shared a heartwarming
instagram post that showed their final
year together in the form of fun video
clips the series of 11 short videos and
one christmas themed photo shows what
the couple got up to during their final
year together from cooking and doing
push-ups to wearing funny costumes and
generally goofing around rizzo wrote
does the accompanying text another year
of fun with this one sorry december got
a bit lazy bob saget's death came as a
shock to many perhaps in part because
his last 12 months seemed so productive
and vital still at least the world can
be thankful that he continued to channel
his personality and comedic talents into
a multitude of creative projects for the
millions who love him to enjoy